[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci d'être avec nous alors
aujourd'hui voilà c'était le sujet du
jour on est avec nous Michael biberon
Michael bonsoir Michael merci vous êtes
pompier secrétaire général se passe 10
CFTC grégorygeron policier salut Grey
conseils
un jour
ça va bien secrétaire général unité LGP
police et Thierry Paul Valette bonsoir
Thierry merci d'être là Thierry Paul
citoyen engagé sur place lors de la
manif alors déjà avant de parler de la
manif regardez aujourd'hui dans les
manifestations contre la réforme des
recettes on a vu beaucoup beaucoup de
choses et les gens on va démarrer par
des choses un peu drôles qu'on a vu il
s'est passé pas mal de choses on va
revenir sur toutes les images vues en
télé sur les réseaux sociaux mais juste
avant qui dit Greff di SNCF et ça m'a
rappelé une énorme rigolade une image
d'archives en 98 un train arrive en gare
avec beaucoup de requins avec beaucoup
de retard regardez la réaction des
passagers un peu vénère regardez
j'en ai ras la casquette
[Musique]
vous êtes des connards
alors ce matin on a eu droit à un moment
lunaire sur BFM TV c'est l'image qui a
fait le buzz alors que la journaliste
interroge une passagère qui allait
prendre son train et bah elle raconte
comment ça se passe pour vous ce matin
20 pour l'instant il y a pas beaucoup de
gens comme d'habitude
je crois que vous êtes dans quel état
d'esprit ce matin ouh là là est en train
de partir
j'ai perdu le train
je suis navré vous êtes dans quel état
d'esprit ce matin vous comprenez la
grève
[Musique]
et nos grévistes ont du talent aperçu
maintenant une invention géniale ils ont
adapté un chariot avec un barbecue pour
qu'il puisse rouler sur les rails du
tram ça a très drôle aussi regardez ça
arrive
[Musique]
on a alors aujourd'hui il fait froid
aussi on a découvert la nouvelle
chorégraphie des manifestants très
utiles pour se réchauffer un peu moi
j'ai dansé ça toute la journée
perdre notre vie à la gagner mais pour
Macron
donner Macron
peu importe les comptoirs donc cette
réforme soit régression ils veulent
moins de
dépenser soi-disant pour gagner du prix
c'est surtout trop que nos vies pour le
profil
quand on
[Musique]
serait-il
la faute
pendant la manifestation où nous sommes
allés on est on a envoyé nos équipes au
cœur de la foule et pendant la
manifestation d'un demander aux gens
qu'elle serait leur proposition pour
contrer la réforme des retraites vous
allez voir on est sur des propositions
qui ont pas finir tout de suite à
l'Élysée regardez on a écouté les
propositions des Français visiblement
cette dame connaît à peu près les
dirigeants du CAC 40 ça serait quoi la
solution à la solution c'est de prendre
l'argent où il y en a il est où l'argent
c'est les grands milliardaires du CAC 40
Lévy ce manifestant a eu la meilleure
proposition on se demande vraiment
comment on n'a pas pu y penser avant
vous préconisez une retraite à quel âge
le plus tôt possible c'est à dire
18 ans bon on est aussi tombé sur le
manifestant qui se pose qui fait là quoi
tu proposes quoi
la laisser où elle est voir la BC
a
58 si c'est possible et on vous a gardé
le meilleur pour la fin on a trouvé le
mec qui est déjà dans le turfu il y a
plus de des robots maintenant pour faire
les choses il y a plus de taf de toute
façon laissez-nous prendre notre temps
vraiment les richesses
et lors de cette manifestation on est
tombé sur des têtes voilà sympathiques
aussi on a même rencontré une presque
star internationale regardez
TPMP s'est rendu à la manifestation et
on est tombé sur des gens un peu
atypiques comme ce mec mikaïra
migladiateur un dernier petit message au
gouvernement ça serait lequel
moi je suis gilet jaune du premier acte
donc j'ai pas spécialement envie de
parler au gouvernement il est dans un il
est dans un bras de Sarah les gars wesh
on a aussi découvert ce mec qui a chopé
la coupe de Pierre Richard qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ici Félix et ben c'est la
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites donc on manifeste parce qu'on
est contre et puis on agile qui
visiblement et le frère d'une grande
star internationale vous vous appelez
comment j'ai le Schumacher
d'accord bon les manips ça creuse du
coup on a voulu se faire un petit
casse-dalle et puis finalement bon on
s'est ravisé mais du coup c'est combien
pardon je suis désolé
et on a vu les mecs les plus sérieux de
la terre mais avec des têtes de ouf il
faut une prise en compte de ses
caractéristiques là pour justement
diminuer le temps de travail et le
départ en retraite et de retour avec
notre gladiateur kaïra qui a décidé de
pousser la chansonnette
si les hommes gilet jaune
[Musique]
on a d'autres images on a d'autres
images qu'on va vous montrer dans un
instant juste je voudrais qu'on voit
l'image cette image d'un pompier voilà
puisque il y a un monsieur qui a voulu
avec un drapeau regardez cette image qui
a fait le tour regardez
yo yo ensuite
vous devriez avoir
c'est honteux ça c'est une image très
forte
votre collègue vous auriez fait la même
chose
est-ce qu'on peut aujourd'hui laisser
entacher l'emblème français par
intermédiaire d'essayer de brûler un
drapeau non alors que nous dans notre
éthique de sapeur-pompiers ou défend de
la cabane de jardin jusqu'au château
de la même façon et aujourd'hui on
défend le patrimoine français je trouve
incroyable votre collègue là donc là
effectivement il est il est en colère
effectivement les mots dépassent un
petit peu bilan en colère oui en colère
il a raison voilà il est en colère il a
on n'a pas en fait à faire ce genre de
choses
on n'est pas d'accord quand une réforme
certes mais effectivement on n'est pas
là non plus pour entacher justement ceux
qui viennent s'exprimer alors on va
revenir sur des images de nos équipes
dans un instant mais il y a aussi des
débordements regardez aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
alors
est-ce que c'est normal Grégory joueron
qui est des débordements comme ça dans
une magnifique
je trouve que c'est important de
souligner comme que c'est des bords de
mon là ils ont quand même lieu en dehors
du cortège c'est ça c'est important de
le dire très important sur les
manifestants voilà qui se font des
grosses difficultés derrière
manifestations c'est justement d'avoir
des effets des éléments ultra qui
noyautaient les cortèges et ce qui rend
quand même extrêmement difficile
l'action de mes collègues sur le terrain
parce que finalement les Black Blocs on
le sait se dissimulent justement au
milieu des manifestants qui viennent ils
s'exprimer ce qui est assez logique
c'est un droit fondamental en France et
heureusement et ben aujourd'hui je
trouve que c'est très bien parce que les
cortège syndicaux ont fait le taf les
services d'ordre des grandes
confédérations on fait le boulot les
Black Blocs ou
ultra violent on appelle ça comme on
veut on s'en fout j'ai pas envie je
trouve que j'étais un très inquiet et il
y a alors il y a eu beaucoup de monde et
c'est très bien voilà parce que c'est
important voilà sort dans la rue mais je
trouve que ça s'est plutôt bien passé
très beau ça c'est voilà c'est c'est
important on avait on était tous un
petit peu inquiet qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Thierry
Paul Valette vous êtes un citoyen engagé
vous étiez bien sûr sur place lors de la
manifeste oui exactement je sors mon mon
sentiment normalement mon sentiment il
est il est assez large bon c'est vrai
que ce qui s'est passé ça aurait pu être
pire ça aurait pu être dramatique il y a
eu quand même quelques blessés et
j'étais présent j'y étais on avait très
peur même vous je suis sûr que voilà non
mais je suis vraiment ouais il aurait pu
avoir un mort c'est ça voilà je suis
même étonné qui est pas encore eu un
mort lors de ce type de rassemblement et
même des années précédentes et que le
mouvement des gilets jaunes voilà il y a
eu des gros dégâts quand même oui oui
mais vraiment des des morts
affrontements frontal euh maintenant on
en arrive là pourquoi moi j'ai toujours
été un citoyen engagé j'ai toujours
dénoncé la violence j'ai toujours été
pacifiste maintenant malheureusement
quand je vois ces images c'est pas que
je m'y suis habitué parce que j'ai pas
envie d'avoir ami habituer mais
maintenant je comprends la colère qui
s'exprime et malheureusement on a un
gouvernement on a un président qui
aujourd'hui il en est soigne d'ailleurs
il s'est fait huer et a juste titre en
Espagne il n'a pas été présent c'est une
forme de mépris les citoyens les
Français vivent de la violence verbale
de la violence d'État de la violence
sociale cette réforme est également une
violence sociale méprisante donc bien
évidemment il n'entend que quand il y a
de la violence c'est ça qui est terrible
si on avait des manifestations ça se
passait bien on nous entendait dans ces
moments-là moi je dirais chapeau bas ce
n'est pas le cas il faut toujours que ça
craque il faut toujours tirer sur la
corde il faut toujours allumer la mèche
avant de pouvoir dire ok d'accord
peut-être qu'après on va discuter c'est
ça qui est dramatique voilà et moi je
viens d'arriver à dire et ben voilà
maintenant ben faut que ça pète si ça
pète on va pas nous entendre c'est
terrible c'est dingue vous pouvez pas
dire ça c'est bien parce que c'est pas
possible on peut pas dire ça Thierry
Paul Valéry voilà on a on a un policier
ici je suis désolé si on peut le faire
mélanger les gens parce que ceux qui se
font ceux qui sont allés ils sont
laissés aller à Jean les actions c'est
pas les manifestants ceux qui sont venus
exprimer leurs colères on y était
d'ailleurs vous assurer que nous on n'a
pas jeté des mortiers sur les policiers
on n'a pas essayé de cramer un abri un
abribution une bagnole non mais je pense
que justement je pense qu'il faut pas
tout mélanger ceux qui sont là qui s'en
prennent à mes collègues justement dans
ces manifestations ils ont rien à
demander ils en ont rien à [__] de la
retraite pour casser strictement rien à
[__]
les gens et je pense que quand on veut
justement faire bouger les lignes c'est
pas au travers de justement ces actions
là qui desservent exactement le message
qu'on veut faire passer Michael c'est
comme le mec qui a un bruit qui brûle le
drapeau est-ce qu'il a la même
revendication que nous non allez toucher
au drapeau français là on touche un
symbole la police
je rentre pas ça légitime mais il faut
se mettre aussi à la place de toute
façon du mouvement des gilets jaunes les
Champs-Élysées c'était aussi des Black
Blocs il y avait quelques gilets jaunes
marginales mais on a stigmatisé ces gens
là on les a stigmatisés volontairement
pour nuire et décrédibiliser le
mouvement aussi donc maintenant quand il
y a de la violence les gens ne cherchent
plus à faire la part des choses ils ne
cherchent plus à comprendre j'entends ce
que vous dites mais vous êtes dans votre
rôle vous êtes à votre place et moi je
suis à la mienne aussi vous comprenez je
suis à la mienne parce que la mienne
c'est celle d'un citoyen un citoyen qui
est en colère comme beaucoup par rapport
à une violence d'État bon et comme je le
dis on a un gouvernement qui aujourd'hui
j'avais un sommet qui était prévu depuis
longtemps qu'est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il aurait dû depuis longtemps
certaines formes des retraites elle
était pourtant pas prévu le président
l'avait dit lui-même et pourtant dans un
contexte où les gens ils ont un genou
deux genoux à terre on leur a mis la
corde autour du cou et maintenant on
leur tire sur le nœud bon si c'était un
président rassembleur qui avait compris
que sa réforme elle touchait qu'elle
humiliée parce qu'il y a de
l'humiliation aussi sociale il aurait
dit très bien je reste je reste c'est
pas un enjeu non plus primordial que de
cette déplacée alors on va pas changer
profondément le sens des choses aussi à
vous parler d'Emmanuel Macron nous on a
rencontré un couple magnifique qu'elle a
la manif ils avaient un message pour
Emmanuel Macron surtout ils avaient les
slogans les plus drôles de la planète
regardez
si vous avez un message pour Monsieur
Macron
qui retire cette réforme
mais en plus
j'espère que les manifs qui en ce moment
ça va porter ses fruits
monsieur se balade pendant que en France
il y a des problèmes vous allez
manifester oui c'est vrai ah super et on
va rejoindre la manif là-bas d'accord
est-ce que vous avez un slogan
c'est pas mal ça pour cet après-midi
3 2 1 5 de la retraite
on est tombé aussi sur la scène la plus
lunaire de l'histoire c'est une
rencontre entre une petite mamie et un
jeune vous allez le voir ça commence
très très mal mais ça finit très bien
regardez
et les pauvres la réforme des retraites
votre retraite en France
pardon aurez-vous votre retraite en
France à la retraite en France oui quand
vous aurez 60 ans vous serez en France
non madame
vous pensez qu'il serait où donc
tu ne seras pas en France c'est tout
c'est-à-dire vers où j'en sais rien
c'est son problème
moi je suis retraité j'ai 80 ans et je
pense que si j'avais travaillé plus loin
que 60 ans je ne pourrais pas vivre
aujourd'hui
l'homme l'être humain et l'être humain
aujourd'hui il est complètement bafoué
et magnifique
on est aussi tombé sur un mec qui change
d'humeur le plus rapidement du monde il
est passé de Valérie Benaim à Gilles
Verdez en une seconde
un petit mot pour le gouvernement
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous montrer d'autres images que
c'est important aussi voilà il y avait
une bonne il y avait quand même une
bonne ambiance non mais c'est important
je voudrais dire et c'est vrai que et
moi je trouve je leur dis bravo à tous
les manifestants et tous les mecs des
syndicats parce que franchement il y
avait une bonne ambiance et ils ont
voilà ils se font entendre mais voilà
les mecs étaient hyper sympa même dans
la manif je vous le dis on a envoyé nos
équipes et merci eux d'ailleurs d'être
d'avoir été aussi sympa avec nos équipes
on est tombés aussi sur un mec qui était
contre la réforme des retraites il a
essayé de nous expliquer pourquoi mais
le problème c'est qu'on a absolument
rien compris regardez et dites-nous sur
nos réseaux si vous avez compris un bail
regarde
vous en pensez quoi de la réforme des
retraites monsieur moi non non je me
retrouve avec des trimestres en plus
donc je vais me retrouver avec des
tribus sur moi donc pas de surcote donc
il me bouffait sur côte il faut aller
plus loin ben moi je me retrouve
normalement je devrais avoir ma retraite
à 60 ans ouais à la base il me demandait
169 donc normalement j'arrive 173 ils
vont me réclamer 174
j'ai deux ans d'écart avec mon épouse
donc normalement je devrais attendre
deux ans mais là je devrais attendre
quatre ans avant qu'on soit une retraite
ensemble ok surtout si c'est les
bisexiles on s'en sort plus donc voilà
non mais ça c'est donc ça c'est plutôt
bien passé mais sache de fond est passé
voilà c'est justement ça s'est bien
passé parce qu'en fait malheureusement
quand il y a des événements particuliers
notamment le drapeau parce que c'est la
première chose que qui a attiré l'oeil
quand il se passe forcément des choses
et bien c'est chose qui ressortent à
chaque fois tandis que là le message est
clairement passé on n'en veut pas de
cette retraite il y avait combien de
personnes il y avait énormément
énormément de monde on va dire
centaines de milliers
de guerre du Nord République c'était
vraiment beaucoup de monde mais combien
il y en avait selon la police alors
selon la police manifestante ou la
police à l'extérieur des manifestations
parce que moi le ministère de
l'Intérieur un million voilà
non mais moi je dis quand même quelque
chose après vous dites que le message il
est passé il est passé enfin là-haut je
crois pas qu'il passera le message de
tout façon ils ont prévenu Emmanuel
Macron a prévenu il sera pas en marche
arrière il n'entendra pas il n'écoutera
pas donc jusqu'où il va falloir aller
pour il y aura du recul il y aura
d'autres mouvements
là je suis pas d'accord
on est qu'à la première journée
mobilisation en 1995 et 2019 c'est
pareil c'est aller crescendo donc tout
peut aller crescendo par contre là où je
me réjouis finalement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même vu des
gens voilà des gens qui étaient contents
d'être là de se trouver pour une cause
commune il y avait de la chaleur il y
avait de l'humanité j'aurais aimé
frissons et ça c'est encore beau et ça
ça laisse de grosse surprise on a
rencontré un copain de la maison par
contre on était censé toujours pas ce
qu'il foutait là regardez
monsieur pour ou contre la réforme des
retraites
écoutez j'ai 61 ans donc je sais pas si
je dois être pour ou contre je suis
juste à l'intersection donc je vais
bientôt la prendre donc simuler pas si
les jeunes se les arrange moi je suis
pour si ils sont cons je suis con moi je
suis avec eux c'est quand la retraite
pour vous 62 et 4 mois ah oui d'accord
vous comptez la prendre ben je l'ai déjà
prise j'en suis je suis presque on a ATP
et qu'on bosse aussi peu que moi on est
déjà en retraites
[Applaudissements]
un dernier mot à dire je voulais voilà
je voulais rebondir il a entendu
puisqu'il a pris il a la parole il
n'écoute pas la différence il a pris la
parole il a entendu mais il a bien
entendu il a bien vu que son peuple a
été forcément dans la rue il le fait
jamais mais ça change